[Music]
sadly more violent unrest plaguing
america's cities tonight including a
vicious attack on the streets of new
york
with the very latest as jerome rick
leventhal uh
rick this is vicious sean it's hard to
believe that this could happen
in new york city which is home to the
largest police force in america but it
did
a horrific daytime mob attack right in
downtown manhattan the nypd releasing
this footage
of a group of suspects beating kicking
and robbing a lone victim
who just gotten off a bus from atlanta
on his way home to brooklyn
police say the 26 year old was chased
and attacked by about a dozen people
who punched kicked and cut him several
times
and then stole his pants shoes and
underwear in broad daylight
on the once again very mean streets of
new york city this group of males and
females
began the assault around 11 30 a.m
friday it was just blocks from city hall
sean the victim whose phone was stolen
is now recovering with slash wounds
to his body head and hand those suspects
fled in a van and two cars and police
are asking for help
in catching them sean all right rick
thank you joining us now
dan bongino you know dan you did this
for a living
look at this video i i don't even know
what to say
to me by the way every conservative
condemned what happened at the capitol
talking about one percent of people that
went to that rally
we condemned it now look at what we're
watching here look at this
this is to me is defunding the police
and not speaking out all summer long and
last week
back in portland and seattle
yeah i mean you have to ask liberal
america a very serious question
is is this is this what you want i mean
you you have
kids a lot of the you know listen i have
a lot of political disagreements with
liberals obviously but
a lot of them are probably loving
parents um don't you have children like
is this
is this what you want in your cities i
mean this isn't happening
across conservative-led cities in
america it's almost exclusively a
phenomenon in liberal cities
now now sean i read a really stunning
opinion piece in the wall street journal
today
um heather mcdonald wrote it and it said
that a staggering
2 000 more innocent americans died this
year due to homicides
than in 2019 and this is happening in
liberal cities
think about that 2 000 people and most
of those people happen to be minorities
are
dead because liberals voted in people
who are incompetent
forest fires jokes of humankind who are
burning these cities to the ground
it's a disgrace dan we better fix it
we got to protect the citizens of this
country thanks for being with us